hello today I'm talking to Sergey
shakiewicz who is a researcher at
checkpoint research and is largely
concerned with the field of cyber
criminals specifically today we're
talking about how cyber criminals use
chat GPT and tools like that in order to
do their bidding there is so much stuff
happening in this area so cyber
criminals are starting to use chat GPD
to do social engineering to construct
malware and I wanted to know just how
imminent is this threat you know how
enabling is it to someone and what does
it mean for the rest I hope you enjoy
and I'll see you around Sergey shukovic
very glad to have you here today thank
you it's pleasure for me to be here
thank you for having me
first of all maybe what is what is
checkpoint research and what do you do
there so checkpoint research is a
research organization in Chuck inside
checkpoint software security the big
company where our organization of what
177 180 people that our goal is
generally to do a research we are not
dealing with statistic security products
or something we are doing research
collecting intelligence in all areas of
cyber security of course it's also to
support our products so understand
what's going on on the other side of the
mostly the side of the bad guys
and also our goal is to contribute to
cyber security Society will also publish
a lot of different researchers just to
be available to sharing knowledge that's
one of our question in our day today we
mostly track cyber criminals hacktivism
Mission State actor and part of what
we're doing also talking to new
technologies and how data and influence
the Cyber threat
when the new language models came out
what was the first thing that you
observed that the let's say call them
bad guys did with it like what what was
immediately accessible to them after
release
in their last November kind of sparkled
a lot of interest from the bad guy I
maybe it's important to mention on uh
we're tracking also a lot of Darker
communities in at least one of the
biggest Russian dark web Forum there was
a section called AI machine learning for
years
but this section was barely barely
active there was one post there months
or so after the release it sparkled it
was a huge huge interest rail cyber
furnace how to use to do something new
like for us
yeah like in for normal people also for
them and the first thing was which all
happened in December 24th pretty quickly
after just gpk launched that a guy
called uspot like U.S Departed
and that of course doesn't have any
connection to a United States Department
of Defense posted the post he called the
python multi-layer encryption tool in
other words it was the code to a rental
a software tool that encrypts file in
normal World it can be a good tool to
protect your data on your machine but in
context of dark web form of course it's
not something good and people see the
code of it and told this is my store
script so keep this in mind and posted
the python script and then just few
hours afterwards another guy asked me
these things a lot like open AI called
trimmer style and then you'll do the
confirm yet open AI gave me a nice hand
to finish the script with knifed code
helicos came back the first time these
guys it was never a developer before
he became I call it alleged developer
because I don't want to really inteller
people who really learn coding
development for a few years
and don't think he's not really a
developer but he was able to create the
software malicious software even the 3gp
video
that will drive him the first real
figure yeah I I think the the uh worry
about this is more widespread that oh
now let's say creating malicious
software is much more accessible and so
on the particular script that this
person created
how hard would it be for me to just find
that somewhere on that dark web Forum
like on some other sub Forum like was it
was it a new script or was it something
that I could just download from
somewhere there conceivably
so I would say it's possible to find
similar scripts yeah but it will require
a bit more of work for example if you
want to you know find such script you
need to find this forum or some specific
repositories in GitHub something like
this you should do some work before
during just much easier just you know
you I'm going to tgpt or Google bars by
the way I'm in this perspectively there
is not much difference or codecs or
other generative ai2 and write what I
want and it provides me so so most of
the tools we saw until now are not
extremely sophisticated that's important
to mention it's not like it's not a
basically a developer can create it or
you never can find it that's still
nothing
um
there there are also other strains here
that people use specifically Also
regarding for example phishing emails
and so on so the scripts I can maybe see
a little bit but I think when it comes
to phishing and social engineering
people say these language models are
specifically Adept to that maybe related
a bit to you know fake news creation oh
I can these they can produce things on a
personalized level how much of that are
we seeing currently in the Cyber
criminal world
so I think it's a great question before
because if as I mentioned in the malware
area we still don't see something really
in top tie or something new in fishing
email we already see that fishing emails
and impersonating content that is
created using the generative AI engines
is much better that we already saw
before that cyber gun has created before
because even now the church Japanese for
example create perfect fishing demos
that can impersonate Bank PayPal
government whoever and the Cyber
criminals can easily use it moreover you
can prompt those engines of AI engines
to a jacket to whatever fishing campaign
you want what do I mean you want to use
fishing gear model with just a malicious
link puts inside the mirror you write
please the craft modification demon that
will urge the user to click a link or if
it's an attachment you just take oh it
should be something that will prompt the
user or an Excel attachment and it
create so it opens thing to play a
really a new a new steel for cyber
performance especially or non-native
English speaker I would say that's
especially because for example the
Russian guys the more sophisticated
from Mostly their English level is very
low up to non-exist and until now what
they did they paid to other cyber
criminals what is called call centers
mostly those are graduates of English
literature colleges in Russia by the way
that consider the very high-end yet
employment or opportunity for those guys
or ladies
so they pay them and those credit for
them fishing demons or so for for a
payment of course now those hypotenuse
don't have to pay don't have to find the
external vendors let's call it and just
can use a check Deputy for it so in in a
sense previously these people didn't
have enough language skills or maybe
also social skills like how do how do I
write a professional looking email and
so on and that can be now produced in a
much cheaper way than having to pay
someone for it yeah I can see that but
it is still it's quite a it's quite an
interesting fact what kind of economies
spring up around these Concepts right
with with people of different skills
somehow finding each other in order to
to achieve
um yeah do are you aware of any high
profile let's say phishing attacks that
have been carried out where we know that
uh like GPT models were part of it or is
that still unclear
so with cyber criminals talking about it
but I think it's still very difficult to
tell about a specific fishing giml or
malware that we've seen our data whether
it was created using AI engine or human
beings there are already of course tools
that allegedly tell how it was created
but I think their first positive rate is
still high that you can't really rely on
it so I assume yes but it's something
very difficult to kind of proven
pinpoint yeah this big fishing campaign
was created using jgpt bars or whatever
um is there a let's let's assume we
accept this is the new world right
people are able to use these tools
they're not going to go away uh they're
only going to become more prolific uh
can
chat GPT or similar models also be used
to counter apart from the the detectors
let's say can they be used to counter
these attacks are there novel ways of
Defending
so it's something I think at some point
here of course on the detection gear we
and we have already a lot of engines
even before jgbt based on AI to detect
you know malicious URLs malicious
patterns all these to directly Tackle
fishing games I think yeah it's a it's
kind of throwing different development
stages in the understanding what is the
best way to do it but I think at some
point we'll have to tackle AI with the
you know defensive AI let's call it
there will be no choice for us if
Defender yeah
um there is there is a strain of people
on YouTube who sort of reverse hack like
hack like scammers that try to call them
and try to establish remote connections
and so on so they will take a call from
a scammer the scammer will
ask them to some and establish some sort
of Team Viewer or something like this
and through that sometimes they're able
if this scammer isn't very versed to
sort of take over the scammers computer
or at least I mean at least cause them
some trouble and so on
um maybe I don't know in my thought that
should be possible that essentially you
you use the first line of defense you
use these models to just kind of waste
these people's time and just sort of get
back at them a little bit with their own
tricks because it's maybe not a
sustainable defense
it's an interesting perspective it's
kind of uh Lord to lure those people
with AI and do it it's an interesting
it's traps I think it's less it's more a
kind of anti-social engineering maybe I
would I can tell it it's in a new era of
I think we're generally entering a new
era of social engineering that's maybe
it's a good way to define it so like the
attackers now will be more sophisticated
deep fakes fishing as a Defender also
maybe we should just try to view it the
way you mentioned really how we really
waste the time of the attacker but I
think I think we are still not there I'm
okay
apart from sort of using GPT models to
counter this what is the most
most effective way of combating these
new threats be that you know users being
able to really easily create malicious
code or really easily being able to
create malicious uh
phishing emails and so on like what's
the most promising thing to do
I think
unfortunately maybe the the best thing
is the oldest trick is the awareness to
the people if people should understand
how fishing looks like how how should we
prevented because you know on the
corporate level yeah you can Implement
really better Solutions uh on the end
point on your email all the but as a
regular person who doesn't understand a
lot in cyber security or AI in some kind
of something it starts with the burn
when you receive an email you receive a
call to understand what are the risks
what's going on and I think the B is
different now with generative AI is so
widely available is the cost of each
mistake is much higher because again we
still don't see something extremely
sophisticated that never exists it's
just there are more attacks where the
fishing malware everyone can create so
the cost of your mistake as an end user
or is a corporation just becomes much
higher
what is what is
maybe we've spoken a tiny bit about you
research and articles that have come out
from your side what is the current what
are you currently looking at what are
the current things that you're
interested in and you're seeing maybe
some some more recent research that you
wanna or you can share
so I would say we are now dealing with
two things one is everything connected
to account takeovers of generative AI
accounts for example of church gpp we
see last months months and a half two
months and huge Market of accountable
covers in the dark basically account
takeover is a very old Market that
mostly focused on the financial
institutions account Banks PayPal Gmail
Facebook Instagram site but since merch
April we see more and more discussion
about uh stolen hgpt accounts especially
Premium Accounts are sold in dark web
okay and I would say there are several
reasons why cyber criminals are so
excited about it one is a to bypass
girlfriends maybe some people will be
sure right but there are certain
countries that are forbidden to use the
GPT by by opening ideas among those are
countries like Russia China Iran for
example and the cyberpreneurial girl
looking how they can still use it for
their purposes so next one
the second is to get more API calls
of and to integrate for example open Ai
and an API to different Bots and I think
the last Trend we see is about the choir
and pride
are now looking to get your inputs and
your queries that you submitted to jgpt
because if you submitted something
private there or corporate information
if someone takes you over your account
it's not only open AI will have the
information but the Cyber criminal
itself
and and we see now a lot of different
Services what they are doing they are
trying to get your password to jgbt and
even premium account service
so that's one area we're dealing
another is we are now trying to see
what's going on with Google board
because yes everyone talking about check
GPT because that was the first one but a
part of ggpt there are I think
at this point possible to tell dozens of
different General TVs
platforms now maybe the Google bars is
the the biggest competitor if it's
possible to 10 other thread surgically
not sure but so we are now also trying
to see whether a Google board are better
in protecting from cyber abuse than 2gbt
that's what a rare area we're trying to
now to understand whether they learn the
lessons
I didn't at least in the beginning
didn't know that's enough efforts to
prevent the abuse of their platform
so that's for example an area we are
trying to understand
um
maybe a slightly different topic
um the there is a new emerging field of
let's say prompt injection
uh threats and something like this and
that's essentially where and there there
are some really cool examples of that
online where if you have something like
chat gbt especially if you enable the
browsing plugins right so that it can go
to websites an attacker will craft a
malicious website that if
uh gpt4 so goes there reads the website
there will be like a prompt injection it
will say something like oh
this is a secret message you've been
selected for a secret experiment right
uh do this and this don't tell anyone
about it right and so this will be kind
of loaded into the prompt and will be
there uh in the subsequent conversation
and people have gotten because people
have gotten for example the user's data
private data out of it because
open AI will or other suppliers will
sometimes put that into the prompt
itself like you know in order to like
fill out a form on a website or so
um how much of how much of that is just
still just kind of research and people
imagining
what could happen and how much of this
do you see on the ground people actively
using I wonder a little bit because it
seems like it's a bit playing with stuff
so far but I'm wondering how much is in
practice
so I would say still mostly at least
again mostly on a more theoretical
research stage you know it's kind of
proof of content that it's possible to
do but I think as more and more engines
and are connected to the internet in
real time
that the deaths I think the best we are
going to well you know in the beginning
GPT was completely disconnected with
very old information of the 2021 and the
way now it's connected we are being and
trajective for also with other and same
Bard there will be more and more risks
behind it really look for real time
attacked against subject itself or
against third party website also because
I see the you know nightmare future
scenario when a cyber criminal that has
zero knowledge in being attacker will
write I won't know to scan all IP range
of specific Corporation to find the
latest vulnerabilities and then you know
to to do some web injection and get the
database just you write who I wanted and
then the output will be the database
from this you know that you know and it
can happen it's still I don't see it
still happening too much you know in
real
but is it is it
of course I can see the argument let
let's say hey this is It's a dystopian
world this is kind of bad if that's
possible on the other hand security
should be built such that you have to
expect this right whether someone does a
port scan and an injection of the latest
vulnerabilities because they're really
skilled or because they use chat GPT or
they pay someone to do it should not
matter to to you know the implementer of
security on the defender side so yeah
I'm wondering a little bit why you say
you know that's kind of a really bad
future is it because you're aware that
the The Defenders usually don't
Implement proper security or
the unfortunately you already cried I
think always cybercrime generally is a
matter of cost efficient because
cybercrime is a business yeah and just
using AI engines those activities will
be much easier and cost efficient for
cyber criminals because now they should
do some manual work on such is scanning
even with all automation they have and
they have autonomics but they will help
to collect some intelligence a lot of
organization to find IP range such stuff
you know and to do some set of
activities still manual even though you
know the scanning is automated using air
agents all this will be automated they
will say oh they take all the Rangers
appropriation in certain countries can
it do it you don't need to understand
you barely need to understand what is IP
you know you will just tell just came so
I think that's the problem and of course
there are a lot of Defenders and
corporations that do not Implement all
the relevant measures definitely but
it's just a matter now it will be just
much easier it's not like it's not
happening now it
um
we've spoken a lot about cyber criminals
and so on which is it's a business right
but these people are let's say either
part of a network or independent you
know they trade on markets and so on the
other
fear that people have that's very
related to it is the future of warfare
like once bigger actors come into play
once State actors come into play and so
on
um what do you see on that or do you
have first do you have any knowledge
even of of that front end what do you
see the future of
to me that's still a bit of an ominous
future like people say the future of
warfare will change there will be like
AI Warfare I'm not too sure how that
might look right what what do you see in
the future of you know geopolitics or
Global Warfare or anything like this as
far as your as far as you can see or is
you're aware
so first of all I don't have any
specific information about what the big
nation but it's someone who in the past
share with an intelligence organization
in Israel I can definitely tell that
based on Mayan or understanding how
intelligent organizations work I am sure
that the countries like Russia or China
for example are actively trying to find
vulnerabilities for example in church
GPT I'm sure they want to find their you
know whether to get the data in the
input or
furthermore to manipulate the date
because I think that will be also always
the question how much we can rely on the
output we get because of course there
are it's not perfect even now we see a
lot of mistakes misinformation but we
assume it's not intended but now let's
assume some country gets an excess and a
fine sound vulnerability that allows
them to manipulate certain information
for example every information about the
Russia Ukrainian war and anything about
this will be presented only in a certain
way so I'm looking in this perspective
because I think we are now in the era of
information misinformation business
information
so if you are talking about you know all
the problems in social media when it
will come to a generative AI engine
I think it will be much more complicated
much more confident so that's definitely
one area I see what
in general do you think
um like what can be done against any of
that people also afraid who in the
future we're gonna all content will be
AI generated we won't know what's true
anymore
uh things like this I can definitely see
a way to this but what can be done about
it like in the same way
awareness is probably as you said before
one of the key factors but then what can
we done about it how can we know
something is still true
in the future
it's a great question I think we will
have to build completely new methods or
for fact check I think it because I
already saw numerous stories about you
know different alleged facts that church
bikini invented and even provided
references to newspaper like the
guardian or washing components
Washington Post or something for a
article that never exists but the
scientifically did provide you know the
URL of it so I think we'll have to build
a new method how we're doing fact
checking check it all I think if you are
talking that maybe some professions will
disappear now with General TV AI so
maybe Dozer will be in a new profession
how to verify you know the information
by open AI you know the ethics of AI
Aldi that now bear you know there are
people who are doing it but it's not you
know it's not the tens of thousands of
people or something so I think we should
maybe look on this this way okay
um last question from me is there any
anything else you would want to get out
to people any words of advice or any
cool new things to look out for
so I think first of all we talked a lot
about the bed sides of AI generative AI
a bit mentioned but I think they're also
a good good sign a lot of good sites and
like every new technology with human
being should look on how build it and
that's what will you know to build the
path of this technology it will use it
for bed yet it will be a better
knowledge that we can bring us to
disasters and more cyber attacks and
everything but it will look how we
protect the world better how we create
new things I think that's a big
opportunity of so I think it's mostly
about how we take this technology and
what we do
do you do you think the path to that
because that's a big discussion right
now do you think the path to that should
be to mostly open up the technology to
as many people as possible to have as
much of the tech available let's say
publish the weights and
democratize it quote unquote or do you
think this other approach of saying No
it should it should be shepherded by a
few big corporations so that they can
make sure people use it responsibly like
there's Arguments for both sides which
what do you see more likely
I think at this point I think now we
don't have way back to limit it already
it's I think it's too late so I think do
you think it should be Democratic but I
do think the rule should be some at
least basic regulation
in a worldwide regulation you know like
uh on everything connected to flights
and Aerospace there are you know
International regulations and all the
countries get to some basic you know
because they don't know what's a
disasters to happen the same here and
it's a big question about what
regulation should we regulate how it's a
completely you know there are a lot of
ethical legal and technological
consequences but I I don't think we
already have a big
totally Limited in fact we should know
maybe stop and think what what exactly
will regulate how how verify that if
there is more use of AI we're able to
investigate it for example to find who
did it but the I guess the I'm not gonna
but my estimation will be the Cyber
criminals aren't going to be too
impressed by regulations but by means of
being cyber criminals already so
um
what what you know what kind of
regulations do you have in mind to make
life easier
with regards to cyber criminals I think
first of all there is never any
regulation any load does not reduce
crime to zero whatever we do you know
never introduces but I think we should
just make the bar a bit higher than each
now not because yeah the sophisticated
cyber criminals will find in Nano the
way like now sophisticated criminal
Bridge B Corporation or government still
but they bar is much higher not every
script PD is able now to breach I don't
know U.S government or a Fortune 500
company
so I think here we should make the bar a
bit higher for a cyber companies on this
I think that's mostly yeah okay that
makes sense Sergey it was a pleasure
having you here and thank you so much
for speaking to me
thank you for the pleasure everyone